[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
whose job is great whose husband is
great whose life is great and she's
waiting for the next shoe to drop we
also talk to a woman who's moving and
she doesn't know how to tell her kids
and we talk about sex baby with parents
and kids stay tuned
[Music]
yo yo what's up
this is john with the dr john deloney
show
talking about mental health
relationships school
the bonkerness that is 2022.
all of it anything
is it bonkers that's not a word
whatever's going on in your life we're
here to talk about it give me a shout at
1-844-693-3291
that's
1-844-693-3291 it's not bonkerness it's
madness absolute madness but we're
getting through it and i'm keeping my
chin up and we're gonna walk alongside
each other as we figure this out or go
johndaloni.com
ask a s
k
kelly
check it out i know look at you you're
on a book i know
dude the cover's here if you're watching
on the youtubes check it out my new book
i can't even believe this to be holding
this this feels weird
this feels strange
own your past change your future not so
complicated approach to relationships
and mental health and wellness
this is it guys this is it go to
johndaloni.com
pick up a copy of this thing man hey
listen
i'll walk you through a common sense
approach in this book i think we have
over complicated mental health we've
overcomplicated being well we've
overcomplicated relationships we've just
turned all this into madness and it's
not
that hard
that's not true it's very hard it's not
that's it's not it's simple it's not so
complicated very very hard
we're gonna walk alongside you step by
step you figure out why you feel lonely
all the time exhaust all the time while
your relationships are screwed up while
you're struggling
all this madness and nonsense man we're
gonna get into it
and um if you've bought redefining
anxiety
this is a this one's a big kid book it's
a real book and i am proud of it so
listen
go to
johndaloni.com
and if you order now you can pre-order
today for only 20 bucks you'll get 100
free bonus items including one month of
free counseling for betterhelp.com they
stepped up to they believed in this book
they stepped up and said hey we're going
to put our money where our mouth is i'm
so grateful for that free copy of the
e-book audiobook other stuff go to
johndaloni.com and order a copy this
book is 20 bucks and it will change your
life change your friend's life change
your
relationships inside your home outside
your home i really believe strongly in
this book so thank you so much for
supporting it and go to john elena come
and check it out all right hey kelly
we were talking before the show started
you got a note from the interwebs
about uh there was gonna be a caller on
the show then they ended up having to
back out
tell me what's going on with that call
so we had a guy that emailed in that
has been seeing a counselor now i don't
know all of the details because he
wasn't on the show but based on his
email
he felt that his counselor had really
breached the confidentiality
pact or whatever that he was telling him
the legal requirement is
he was
just bumping a high five
um him he was telling
him things about other clients and he he
felt sure that he was that his uh he was
telling other clients things about him
no
no no no no no no
he wanted to know if he should report
him ah okay listen if you're listening
to this or watching this
listen watch can we say it like that
few things
damage
the credibility of helping profession
like bad science does
and unethical
therapists unethical counselors who do
things like hey i need you to help me
out with this project or i need you to
sell my book for me or i need you to
um
uh
i i need to talk to you about one of my
other clients to see what you think or
i'm talking to this other client and
they're struggling with the same
absolutely no
no
absolutely don't don't don't if you are
in a situation where you think your
counselor is being unethical
please
consider reporting it
all you have to do is google report
therapist
and
you can make a complaint with the local
thing now listen if you don't get along
with your counselor you think they're
annoying you think that jokes aren't
funny
that's don't report that then you beat
people up
um and it's expensive to go through that
process
but if you're talking to somebody who's
unethical
who is
hurting people who is trying to force
you into their way of seeing the world
and not walking alongside you and
helping you with your problems
then you need to say something
i invite you to say something how about
that you know people who are struggling
don't need somebody piling something
else on them i invite you to say
something yes if you are seeing a
therapist and they are telling you other
stories about other clients
god almighty report that today report it
today
report that
it's so hard to get the courage to go
see a counselor to go see a therapist go
see a psychologist go see a doctor it's
so hard to get the courage to go do that
and then to have most people who go are
struggling with relationship issues
that's the core of all the stuff it's
relationship dysfunction
and to get there and then find that the
one person that you finally have the
courage to go trust is going to violate
that relationship by telling your story
to somebody else or telling you somebody
else
man i want them out of the profession
get them out of there man get them out
of there
if you're brave call them on it say is
it appropriate for you to be telling me
stories about other people
or are you telling me this is another
client and you're just making that up as
a as a teaching device
because i'm really uncomfortable that
you might tell my story to somebody else
call them on it
call mine
but i don't want those
people doing therapy and if you are in
the counseling profession
few things nothing is more sacred than
confidentiality hold it hold it tight
don't tell your friends don't tell your
spouse
hold that tight that's holy and it's
sacred
keep it
all right let's go to allison and
washington do you mean get me all fired
up kelly we haven't started the show yet
trying to be all happy selling the book
and then
hey look who showed up james is here
hmm
pulling a deloney huh showing up five
minutes late my nap got cancelled so
you're you're what my nap oh you're dead
speaking of cancelled the show we were
going to tonight james and i were going
to a concert the same one
and they play vendors
they do and they cancel it stupid
coconut all right let's go to allison in
washington dc what's up allison
hi john um firstly congratulations on
the book i'm really excited to read it
thank you
if you and my mom
i mean that's at least two copies that's
fantastic so i'm grateful for that my
mom's not gonna actually buy this one
she's just gonna ask me to mail her one
so what's up
so i'm calling because
throughout my life i'm in my early 30s
if one thing was going well in my life
something else wasn't
and
i'm finally at a point where literally
everything is awesome
and
i
feel
kind of guilty that it's like that and
then also struggling with a little bit
of anxiety of like oh no what if this
all goes away
so i'd like your advice to kind of
figure out how to
enjoy where i'm at without
worrying about ending or feeling guilty
that i've achieved so much wow okay um
i've
man i have felt that so
when you say
you spent part of your life where
something good was happening and
something else was always negative
negatively impacting you
i i challenge that so give me an example
so i have cerebral palsy so i grew up
with a disability well then you drop
cerebral palsy on me so way to go
allison you win that you win that one
we'll play oh well okay so
watch me i was really so i was really
really bullied in school yeah um but
like my family was awesome so like
school was hard dealing with bullying
everything is awesome or like for
example
um
you know my job was going well
and then my husband
uh disclosed some addiction to me that
was really painful
but then we got through that and then my
relationship with him as well and then
job is not great so like
you know but right now i mean i actually
called you and ken coleman back in april
of last year nervous about starting a
job and
i'm doing awesome oh it's so good what's
your job
i'm a financial advisor
awesome and you're just crushing it
yes excellent good for you way to go
yeah so i'm excited so and like my
communication with my husband is amazing
um my parents have apologized i know
that you said that like
parents can't take bricks out of your
trauma backpack but they kind of feel
like hey we realized that we didn't
teach you this skill and we're sorry
because we know that it's affecting you
negatively now
my in-laws came for christmas and like i
had a great time with them
like
i know it's crazy like john i love my
in-laws they're amazing people wow and
like my relationship with my sisters
like everything is great
excellent um and you know not and
you hear that little jaws
the soundtrack right in in the back of
your mind
yeah just waiting for the next bad thing
yeah exactly and so i'm trying to figure
out
how to not have that you know soundtrack
playing in my mind of like everything is
great and it could all be gone tomorrow
yes
okay
oh man this you're number one you're a
rock star what a gift you're a gift to
humanity and i'm grateful for you
um number two
you you this just just by having the
courage to call you're gonna help a lot
of people because this is something that
so many folks struggle with especially
through kovid because i worked with a
lot of business leaders through covet
who had the best years of their life
and their employees who didn't quit had
the best i mean it was it was incredible
and they didn't know what to do they
don't have to say anything because they
thought they were they felt so guilty
because we were supposed to be in this
collective morning and we were
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of people have died it's been
a national calamity not to mention this
right right so people i don't know what
to do i don't know how to do it and so
your question is so on point and it's so
relevant right now
so
you have a heightened
set body
let me say it this way
um
your brain
is extra attuned to making sure
it points out all of the potential
dangers in the world
yeah
because
it has experienced
trauma through cp how how aggressive is
your is your cerebral palsy
like if you did if you didn't know i had
it
it like you know i i walk with a limp
but that's about it okay so you're
mobile
yeah okay all right um
and so
the fear of carrying that around with
you the bullying when people don't know
it that that you're struggling with
something and they just are going to
make fun of the way you walk but your
body has had to deal with that forever
your heart and mind have had to deal
with that forever and then to hear that
your parents may not have handled it
great too your friends and family so
your brain has been scanning its
environment for safety forever
and you know my parents really did
handle it well it was literally just
that like kids are awful kids are the
worst the worst like my my dad and mom
every day would be like we're so proud
of you we love you very much so they
handled it amazingly so it's mainly just
like
every everything kind of outside was
really difficult okay
so
you find yourself and you've worked
through some hard stuff you've had hard
marriage stuff which we all have you've
had hard work stuff and the insecurities
and then now you're crushing it so
here's reality i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna be as honest as i can with you
it could all go away tomorrow
you work as a financial advisor
if you're an honest financial advisor
you tell your people
your clients
i think this is the right thing to do
this is how i use how i
invest my money
but as we all know apple might all just
be a charade right it might all it just
could all go away so it's living in that
tension of it could all go away and it's
probably not going to
right
so
here's what i want you to do
what does guilt feel like in your body
what does it feel like
it just kind of feels like
tightness in my chest of like you know i
have been so incredibly blessed and
there are people who have worked just as
hard who have done just as much
that aren't like even like i mentioned
addiction like my sister is getting a
divorce
um
and was in a very similar situation to
me and my husband so like my husband
went to recovery is currently a sponsor
like chair of his meeting like
killing it in recovery
and like my sister's getting divorced so
it's just it's one of those things where
it's like
why
like why are you an empathetic person
maybe i wouldn't say that's my super
strong as a person
but you know i i i've tried to become
more empathetic as i've gotten older
not celebrating your joy
is not helping their pain
okay so i'll say that again
not celebrating your joy the good stuff
in your life does not help them
yeah
and often we try to identify with those
around us especially when we have a
traumatic background we've grew up in
trauma we want to identify with those
around us and the way we identify is
getting into the sewer with them
not either a putting an arm out and
pulling them out or
sitting next to it
and so one of the greatest things you
can do for those who are struggling
is to do the opposite of what our
natural inclination is
double down and love love your life be
write down i am so grateful for
and so one of the things that i do and i
carry it around with me
i wish i had a a less lame title than
what i'm going to tell you but i just
call it my stories journal
and that makes me sound like i'm a
middle school girl and i get that but
it's just a small thing i bought at the
store and when those kind of
when those stories pop up and i struggle
with guilt i struggle with success i
didn't grow up with a lot
a lot of my friends have done really
well some of them haven't i struggle
with that
and when it pops up i literally will
write it down
i don't deserve a good job right now and
then i will look at it and say is this
true
and so what i'm doing is i write the
story down and i demand evidence from it
okay and often when i write it down i
get it out of my body my body stops
reacting to it and i can look at it
objectively
and i can say no i've worked really hard
i've gotten really really lucky
and i've had people who have mentored me
and taken care of me and who have picked
me up when i've done something stupid or
have rebuked me when i've said something
stupid they've held me accountable
and um
so i'm blessed i'm fortunate
and feeling guilty about that helps
nobody doesn't solve anything
uh and so you get what i'm saying i'm
gonna i'm gonna continually
push on those stories on those old
scripts and the word i wanna give you is
practice
you're going to practice feeling less
guilty you're going to practice feeling
uh gratitude instead of guilt
okay and you're going to do that through
a gratitude journal you're going to
write down four or five things every day
you're grateful for have a memory of
something you're really grateful for
sit down for a minute and just close
your eyes and remember the feeling you
felt when somebody did something
wonderful for you when your husband said
um i'm a year sober when whatever the
thing is you're so grateful
and i want you to write down those
stories and challenge them because we're
going to live in an abundance not a
scarcity there's not a
there's not a um
there's not a
finite amount of joy that can be had in
the world
and if you have too much of it you're
going to take it from somebody else
that's not how joy works
that's not how happiness works and how
how
abundance works
right and hey can i ask you one quick
other question sure yeah where in your
life are you still not safe
and um here's what i mean by safety do
you owe people money do you have debt do
you
um
awesome do you have a do you have a jerk
boss i'm guessing not because you love
your job no my boss is incredible and
the thing is like
prior my prior job was so toxic
but
like even the other day i made a mistake
at work i went to my boss about it and i
was still afraid to literally scream at
me there you go
and he was like okay well yeah like
there's not really anything you could
have done to change that but like in the
future try this so that you won't be as
surprised and so you're hey listen
here's the third thing i'm going to tell
you gratitude journal write on stories
and demand evidence here's the third
thing
i want you to think your body
t-h-a-n-k i want you to think it every
time it takes off on you
okay all it's trying to do is take care
of you why because it's been down this
road before it's been abused by idiotic
kids making fun of somebody with um
disability it has been abused in a toxic
work situation it remembers these
stories the same as if you were a
military veteran and you hear the
gunfire your body remembers that and
says it's time to go right
and so every time your body starts to
take off on you i want you to go
oh there you go hey thank you for taking
care of me i've got this i'm good okay
and over time it won't happen like it's
not magic you have to breathe through it
and go for a walk and all that but over
time your body will settle down and then
you're going to hit something hard right
you'll lose your job something will
happen your husband will say something
stupid
um your cp will accelerate on you
something will happen
and you will have built a reservoir of
resilience your body will be at a place
where it can handle stuff you've been
you've given it strength you've
practiced new way of looking at problems
and
oh my gosh i cannot tell you how proud i
am of you you're a brave woman you're a
strong woman and you are absolutely
getting it
so cool allison so cool congratulations
be joyful and be grateful it's so good
we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back i'm waiting to get
my son
my son uh auditioned for the play and he
finds out at any minute now if he got it
or not
what play i'm looking at you theater
teacher i don't know
i don't know what the play is
i just put that in my application for
father of the year i don't know i just
know he auditioned for something and it
was he had to sing it's the whole thing
i was so proud of him man and um i'm
just waiting to see if he got a part if
he didn't get a part i'm just kidding if
he can get a party that's cool let's go
to bridgette in finley ohio hey bridget
what's up
hi dr jen how are you
um i'm excited to talk to you today i am
more excited to talk to you freezing
and freezing because we got like four to
six inches of snow it was a snow day so
my kids have been home all day
you have that voice of a mom who's
almost at the end of her
snow day rope good for you honestly
hiding in my car right now yeah
i love it
i love it so hey so what's up how can i
help
so my husband has a new job and we are
going to be relocating this summer um so
we are wondering how and when we should
tell our kid where are you going
um two hours south to cincinnati
all right so how old are your kids
um seven so he'll be going into second
grade okay and then four going into
kindergarten um and then we have a six
month old so he's along for the ride
yeah yeah so tell me what your concerns
are
um
i think
i lived in the same town my whole life
though it's hard for me to relate to how
i'm going to
tell my kids that we're moving um the
kindergartner
he
will
i mean be starting a new school so
either way i think
it's not going to be as hard as an
adjustment
where the seven-year-old
is already you know going into second
grade he has his friends he's been in
soccer
um
we also
just built a house like a year and a
half ago so this was supposed to be that
forever home
and
so now it's not
so i think that's
the
i guess hesitation and and selling it
for them because they have to
start over and i think for both of us as
parents like
um starting over as well neither of us
are super familiar with the area
so how honest do you want me to be with
you
all the way
are you
are you positive all right i'm gonna
give you i'm gonna give you
um two things
one is something i just i just i just i
have a whole chapter about this in a new
book
and the second is
um my honest take i think you're the one
struggling
and i think you're struggling because
you've never done this before because
it's hard because you've got a community
and because you've got connections there
and you had a picture of what their life
was going to look like and now your
picture has changed
and it's very very hard
when we are struggling to look in the
mirror and say this is my challenge
because it might be right is it right
that y'all are moving you feel good
about the move
so when we talked about
my husband getting the job he was kind
of head hunted
and this is like his career passion
and the company he worked for
um said we don't want you to do that
anymore so he left and i 100 support
that because having a passion for your
job is awesome
and so then
this other company is saying we want you
to do this and we want to make you like
a director that's just a huge bump
that's such a big deal
um i never wanted to live here in the
first place i just
followed my husband because that's where
his job was and i can work anywhere in
the state working remotely okay
and
the location we've looked at the schools
we've got it like narrowed down we're
big into
having diversity and great in education
and
all the things like a target even 10
minutes from my house yeah amazing so in
the long run we know this is best for
our family
but you're correct like the community of
people we found our church our friends
our neighbors
that's what i think we're struggling
with and because my kids have that too
that's where i know that
i think they'll struggle and so
all of us starting over i think
we're not we can get past that i'm just
trying to figure out how to verbalize
that to our kids so the greatest gift
literally the greatest gift you could
give your kids especially your
seven-year-old
somewhat your kindergartner
is to let them know
this is hard
and that
it's the right thing for our family and
we're excited and daddy's got a new job
and it's going to be this and it's going
to be that
and it's going to be so so hard
and mommy's really going to miss her
friends
the worst thing you could do
would be to tell not tell them that
you're going to miss your friend
not let them see you cry
not let them see you're frustrated when
you're trying to pack and deal with a
newborn and all that stuff
because they're gonna miss their friends
they're not gonna like to pack up their
room
and they're gonna feel like they're the
only one having these feelings and
they're gonna feel nuts
and so
uh i just did this i moved with a
i guess back when we moved it was eight
and
seven or eight year old and then a
three-year-old i guess two or three year
old
and
um
it was hard
and not so much and i took uh we took
our son on the school visits and we took
our daughter as much as we could on her
school visits and
we
let them pick the restaurant when we
were driving around i mean right so we
invited them into the process as much as
we could
and it made the transition so smooth and
i said things like man i'm really gonna
miss such and such your friend
i love that they were your friend and
i'm really gonna miss him and their
daddy was my friend too i'm really gonna
miss him i let my kids know that i was
hurting
and in turn it didn't
make them scared it made them not feel
alone and not feel crazy
and then with
like my hus it's obviously my husband's
job right
i guess not
not so much like the guilt but like
don't wanting them to like blame him
because it's see did you hear your
language they're not going yeah like you
are okay you are no you yes you are and
hey it's okay
it's all right
because it's the it's the right thing
for your family this is your words it's
the right thing for your family i'm glad
he's taking this job and it really
pisses me off we have to leave
those can all be true at the same time
yeah and he knows that but i think he he
specifically mentioned like he doesn't
want them to blame him and he has you
know why because he blames himself
y'all are putting things on to kids that
they're
either are going to be passing
they're going to be fleeting
or they're never going to enter their
mind
if you all tell them this is a new
adventure for our family we're going to
do this and there's a zoo in cincinnati
and we're gonna go to the zoo and
there's a
whatever in cincinnati we're gonna go
there like they'll be all in in 24 hours
or 48 hours
okay so the bribing with the pool
community is good of course he's gone
i mean
that was already on the list you could
take your kids your your kindergartner
to disneyland and if the hotel you stay
at has a pool they're going to talk
about that hotel we stayed up with a
pool for the rest of their life right
they're going to forget disneyland
they're gonna remember the pool right so
i it's not about bribing it's just about
showing them hey there's cool things
here too
okay it's both and
what i don't want you to do is i don't
want your husband to feel guilty there's
gonna be that natural guilt i felt it
when i moved to nashville we moved for
my job to go work at a university
and it was the right thing it was good
everything about it was right all of it
and i still felt bad
because i was making my family have to i
mean
i wasn't making them do anything they
are coming along with me
their life was disrupted because of my
choice
and that guilt is okay
i don't ever want my family to be
inconvenienced or disrupted because of
me and they were
and that disruption was the right thing
to do it was great it's both in
and just like i said you can be all 100
on board my husband's going to make more
money he's going to be happier he can be
doing the things that he loves which
means he's going to love us at the house
it can be nicer to be around
i can take the kids to cool places and
not just rando places and fin whatever
and
i hate that we're leaving i love the our
new house that we built together and
planned together and i love the schools
my kids are gonna go to and all those
things right it can be both and
and here's the second thing i set you up
okay
yeah um
so the first thing is is
your kid's gonna be fine you and your
husband have to be able to live in that
tension and you gotta tell your kids the
truth that you miss people too let them
see you guys grieving this transition it
will be
a great gift for them
the second thing here and i wrote about
it in this new book and it sounds like
i'm trying to pitch something or sell
something and i kind of am but here's
the thing yeah
we have a culture now that is obsessed
that revolves entirely around our
children
how are they feeling do they like me
i don't wanna i don't want them to to be
out of step a little bit i don't want
them to feel a little bit disconnected i
don't be out of place i don't want them
to i want them to like us
and
unwittingly
we have shifted the burden of our
families onto our kids
they're the epicenter
and our children cannot carry the weight
of our friendship of our feelings of our
regrets that's not their job their
shoulders aren't strong enough because
they're little kids
it's cruel to make them do that
the thing that they need desperately is
for us to model for them to make adult
decisions and to tell them this is what
we're doing because y'all are in our
family
you hear what i'm saying
yeah yeah and often man we re-pattern
our lives around their schedules we
report our lives around their
hearts and emotions and feelings now i'm
not saying you're like you're doing
you're doing gymnastics i don't care i
hate gymnastics daddy i don't care next
time i'm talking about you know what i
mean
yeah but i do mean in our house you're
gonna do one activity
you can be quiet it can be knitting it
can be
wrestling it can be jiu-jitsu you're
going to do an activity
and preferably a mobility one we are all
moving as a family and because you're
seven you're moving with us and it is
going to be hard and it's good you hear
what i'm saying there i want your your
life to revolve around you and your
husband's decisions on what's best for
the future of your family not about how
our kids are gonna feel
that makes sense
yeah yeah
so do you feel
excited to move
yeah do you feel sad
yes
i'm sad that i'm losing like the
community that we've formed around us
um so just having to recreate that um
but i'm excited about all the things and
we've known this since
last july
so just as time is coming up it's like
getting more real and i'm a planner so
like
doing
all the planning for
for it and this has been something we've
been thinking about
like i said since we made that choice
that we were going to have to move but
just not sure how to approach it so
let's let them in on the move too by the
way give them a box when you all start
packing and say go load up three things
and let them be a part of it and don't
even fix the box it's just going to be a
box of shenanigans just tape it up and
say way to go and draw pictures on or
whatever um your seven-year-old let him
let him or her a part of the planning
process the list making process if
you're a list maker invite them into
those things
and so when should we tell them because
i just don't want to take away from the
time that
you know he gets to enjoy but i don't
want to spring it on him either when are
you moving
uh after the school year's over that was
my stipulation with the new job is that
he's been working basically remote but
we knew we would need to move in the
next year so i said i wanted the kids to
finish out
this school year because i was about 38
weeks pregnant when he
got the job
so i would i would actually plan a trip
i would take him down to the zoo in
cincinnati
yeah and take the kids down there and
show them what a great town it is i
would do that
and not mention the move maybe take them
down there and take them to a fun
restaurant they're gonna have a blast
i'd let them have a good time in there
you're in your this is an environmental
move first
the the fear of the word move when you
call them in and say we have something
important to tell you
boom they're fully limbic they're not
listening to anything they're just
terrified
and so take them down and give them them
a picture in their mind of what this
could look like
and then in a couple of weeks say hey
daddy you know daddy got a new job
it looks like we're going to be moving
to that new town
and
remember the one with the zoo and we're
going to always point back to those
pictures
okay and then we don't have a house yet
have y'all found a house there yet
no we're in the looking process okay so
maybe let them say point in a couple of
houses you like pull them up online and
let them point at a couple of them we
want ownership in this thing we want
participation never never never lie to
him okay
so don't say like oh we might be moving
no you know we are and so it will be
well looks like we're going to be moving
to this new community
we want you to help us find a house and
invite them in a little bit and say mom
and dad gets to make the final call but
which one do you think you like the yard
you know you hear what i'm saying
um do you want the one with a pool in
the neighborhood and let them yeah
that'd be great
um right so you're gonna invite him
along
always always always remembering
you you and your husband got to stay
connected in this deal i did not move
well it was a disaster
for uh my marriage did not move well
i had different expectations she had
different expectations and i did not
communicate well
disaster okay make sure y'all are
communicating every step of the way hold
that tension the whole way
the this is so the right thing to do and
i'm just gonna cry today and i think you
and your husband need to call that out
this is the right thing and i feel
guilty for moving us and disrupting
everything and taking us away from our
dream home
and i know this is the right thing and i
hate you for moving us i don't really
hate you i love you but i'm just ah it's
both in
and being honest with each other
together through this whole thing making
sure y'all stay
schedule time for intimacy and
connection in this time even though you
got a newborn it's hard with three kids
as it is three kids with a newborn and
moving oh my gosh oh my gosh stay
connected in this process stay connected
stay connected stay connected
and remember the world does not revolve
around your kids
revolves around y'all too and the life
y'all are building for everybody stay
tuned we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
hey i received this email the other day
this is from nicole and here's what she
writes dr dalony my toddler slept
through the night for the first time in
months on his new dream cloud mattress
he said it was so
cozy he has the best mattress in the
house totally worth it for more sleep
thought i'd share thanks nicole good
folks i'm receiving notes like this from
all over people who said it is time for
me to start getting better sleep for
their kids to start getting better sleep
people are saying i want my whole family
to change everything and change begins
with a good night's sleep it is time to
stop sleeping on the mattress you got on
that online marketplace or it's time for
your kids to stop sleeping on a fourth
generation bedroom set on a mattress
that existed before we landed on the
moon and yes we did land on the moon and
look i've made it easy for you dream
cloud is running their biggest offer
ever for dr john dolone show listeners
almost 400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 dollar cash discount
that's a total of
650 bucks in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protector sheets and
they deliver it all to your house
change your life change your kid's life
change your family's life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com or go to
dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney and get
your new mattress and enjoy your savings
today
all right we are back let's take unimas
let's go to greg in lexington kentucky
what's up greg
oh this is getting real now
oh man
i said my wife said at the altar
so what's up
so my wife and i would love to have your
help
on how to navigate
the sex talk with our kids
let's talk about sex babies yeah
that's awesome
love to talk about um
so just give you a little bit
i mean you and your wife want to talk to
about sex i'm just kidding is it with
kids
yeah we'll talk to you i'm not helping
you and your wife talk about sex but
okay so tell me about your kids tell me
what's up
so we have a 10 year old and seven year
old
and
we've always been super honest and
upfront with them about all body parts
and the correct things for them um
all those conversations have there's
never been any embarrassment there's we
don't joke about
body parts and so it's just all
normalized to them
and
the one conversation that we've had with
our oldest
our daughter
is her
upcoming
cycle that she'll be
experiencing
hold on dude
my wife had that conversation she
oh she's she's gonna have a period yeah
not her upcoming cycle that she will be
one day starting soon sir
like you're like you're a robot she's
gonna have a period dude
right
correct say that word
she's gonna have a period hey you did it
all right so she's gonna have a period
not a cycle that one day she will soon
be attempting to begin and start all
right so your wife had the conversation
about having a period
yes okay and it went pretty well she was
kind of weirded out by the thought of it
at first but then
um
shortly after that she just ran to her
brother to tell him the exciting news
crazy yeah
yeah
so
what's your question there
so yeah just
just um how to successfully navigate
that conversation with
uh just the basic sex talk as far as
that you know they've never even asked
us how did how do babies get in mommy's
belly um
you know and
obviously it's it's going to be somewhat
awkward when they figure out what mommy
and daddy do in the bedroom
here's here's the thing it will only be
as awkward as y'all make it
now there will be moments when like when
i say awkward like when they become
teenagers it's more disgusting than
awkward right like i just can't have
that picture in my head right so i get
that
um but the awkwardness so i'll just i
mean this happened in my house i may
have said this on the show i don't know
if i did
this is like three weeks ago okay
this is live in the deloney household
we're sitting down to dinner just
sitting down minding my own dad business
i don't even think i'd wash my makeup
off from work
and i sat down at my table yeah and that
that sounded as bad as you think it does
uh i sat down a table makeup on ready
for dinner wife sits down sun's sitting
down
my daughter who's six
just pulls her chair out to climb up in
it and eat dinner and she goes mom
dad how does the boy part get inside the
girl part
and i was like
i mean i just want to have dinner i did
i hadn't mapped this talk out today i
didn't i didn't really know this was
coming
and my wife
i mean she was i didn't none of it no
one missed a beat i think my son's eyes
probably got a little bit wide just
because he's a he's a good kid trying to
take care of her sister um
and ultimately i said josephine is sex
it's awesome
and this is how this works and my wife
did say later i wouldn't have said that
at the dinner table because that was a
long conversation we ended up right
um
but that's just i mean we just explained
it
and so when you ask me like how do we
address the mother and the dead
they see their own anatomy and you just
explain it as clear as can be with no
weirdness at all
you know what i mean right at all
and when they say do you all do that you
say yes it's
why because it's awesome
or how do you think y'all got here
and there will be a season when they
think y'all have done it three times
and or however many kids you have that
y'all done it three times and then one
day they'll figure out oh gross they do
it a lot yeah you know and that's part
of the best part of being kids
but it's it's that
this is where you can
start a shame process around sex
or you can start a real openness
and a
reverence for
and a
joy around
all in how you all have that
conversation
that's what we want we want the
normalized not the shameful not the
embarrassing i mean it's gonna be bad
like you said embarrassing enough at the
teenage years but at this point
we're trying to
hold that off yeah so it can be as
dramatic
as all right what do you know about sex
tell me
and one of your how old are you you told
me 10 and 7 is that right yes yes all
right so
you you go for uh i don't know the old
the old they're sitting in the back seat
you're sitting in the front seats you
have to look them in the eye
um
we
it's so normed in my house that we
haven't even had a huge event
we did have one where like a mechanics
conversation that i thought i just
crushed and i
i i didn't do a good job of the
mechanics i did a good job of like the
interaction but i just didn't do the
interact the
i didn't
i didn't do a good job but
it wasn't because of the awkwardness it
was just because i explained things
poorly um
but we talk about it so much so it's a
normed thing in our house
and it's not just about sex so often we
think about how to have a sex
conversation
really it's about how do we have the
grief conversation and the tears
conversation and the daddies have
struggling at work conversation and the
mommy's frustrated is choosing to be
frustrated with dad because daddy
doesn't pick up a shoes conversation
we're creating an environment where it
is okay
to feel things and to say that out loud
okay and it's okay too
is that you hear what i'm saying
yeah that's what we were wanting to like
with with both my wife and i we had one
conversation with our parents
yeah exactly
and we're wondering how how to do that
on a continuous basis where just give
them what what information they need
today and if they have questions later
that they might not have today
how do you i don't put the burden of
questions on my kids
i see i give them we have an environment
in our house so they can ask us anything
and god help us all they do holy smokes
um
but
when it comes to
um
when it comes to hard conversations that
i need to make sure they get information
i do not wait for them to come to me
because they live in a world where they
don't have to google will tell them
yes
their friends will tell them and if
their friends can't tell them the
smartphone will
so it's not my responsibility to put
those kind of questions put the weight
of asking that question on my kids i'm
going to bring that to them
while also creating an environment where
that's okay so at this point it so you
say you talk about it a lot
i'm guessing just by your your
your
the way the way you describe
menstruation that you and i are talk
differently in our houses so give me an
example of how you like are open about
sex in your house
no no no no we've been we've been open
about
um the body parts but as far as the
actual section okay okay okay they have
not happened yet okay
no no no so they're 10 and seven
yes so they know about sex
we've asked and they're like what is
that
like
they
they honestly do not okay
i gotta tell you i we we i got fortunate
because we just
we had animals
i'll just put it that way
right right yeah so we we were able and
we talked about what
one time my son when he was just
learning about deer hunting he asked
um
dad do you still go in the rut
i was like yes i do
um not quite like a deer does but yep
and so anyway we talk about animals and
stuff that way but
i i would approach it just directly
and say
we're talking about sex today this is
going to be a com like ask any question
um and i would get right into it man
don't bat an eye about it don't be same
as hey we're going to talk about
architecture today we're going to talk
about
uh our
i don't know
how
we set the tone yeah exactly
and you can do it together
you all can sit at the table so they can
see you all talking about it not being
weird about it
you can go to breakfast together go to
lunch together and talk about it
but the main thing is getting that first
conversation if you all have never
talked about sex out of the way getting
having that first conversation
if your kids can honestly look at you
and say we don't have no idea what
you're talking like what
yeah they're
they're they are that way and they have
no friends that have brought it up with
them
mm-hmm
nope do they go to are they homeschooled
they go to school
no they're public school but even like
we have two dogs and
the one dog will
um
violate some
toys every now and then
and my daughter's just like you know has
no clue she's like he must really like
that
that little stuffed animal he's always
trying to cuddle with it so all you
yeah
all you have to say right there dude
that is that is a gift
it's a gift from the heavens when that
happens all you have to say is that
dog's practicing mating
and you can actually point out the
anatomy on that dog
right right and so
and you can say you know how you have
this part and that and
then
you know
you have this part and this is how sex
works
and i mean it's that simple or it may be
a little bit weird if the dog's just
getting after a stuffed animal that can
be weird for everybody but it can be a
call back right
i can remember when yeah remember
remember when fluffy was
rocking onto the break of dawn with the
with the
the the teddy bear you can call back to
that right the key here is
levity the key here is that balance
between seriousness this is this is an
important topic that i want to make sure
we you hear from me
sex is incredible and it's awesome and
it's
it's um
reserved for these situations and it is
um
it's it's designed and your body's
perfect as it is you know what i mean
it's making sure that those messages get
across and those messages will be judged
on
how comfortable or not comfortable you
are it will also be judged by
how tense you are and how awkward it is
unless you call it out hey this is gonna
be weird but we gotta have this talk
right
and that's my relationship with both my
kids that i if there's something awkward
i'm gonna tell them hey this is gonna be
weird
and they'll go oh here we go dad
whatever it might be right um but i
breach it that way and i'm vulnerable in
that way or or honest in that way and i
don't even i don't think twice about it
i want them to know it's okay to not
know exactly how something's gonna go
and so that at their ages you wouldn't
think it would be
inappropriate to discuss it but both of
them together
uh 10 and seven
yeah are they same gender
no no i'd break them up
okay yeah i'd break that i'd break that
conversation up for their comfort not
for yours
um
it might be weird talking about sex and
they will remember having the sex talk
with their sister or their brother
and so i wouldn't have that conversation
together like that if they were both
sisters they were both brothers possibly
um but we're going for their comfort and
they may want to ask questions they may
want to you know what i mean and i don't
want them sexualizing the other their
brother or sister either
right
so
um i also would not call back to their
brother-sister's parts
right
right um this conversation's about them
and anyway yeah i wouldn't do that
together i would have you know if i'm in
your case i'd have my wife go talk with
my daughter and i would go talk to my
son on this initial conversation and
then in the future
um i've talked to my daughter about sex
my wife talked to my son about it it's
just a part of the rhythm of our house
as are any questions and i think that's
the thing i want to get to after you
have this initial
i'm a safe space here's what sex is and
once you have that initial conversation
then it's about making sure we create a
context where we can ask anything feel
anything be heard on things and then
move on from there
have you seen the books
um
like by robbie harris michael amberley
no i've never seen him no um i do there
are some great children's books on
talking through sex where i see parents
screw that up is they give the book to
their kid and say you read this no no no
no no no no no yeah if you want to read
it with them
fine i i would start all of this with a
conversation though
okay
just a human-to-human conversation is
how it started
because again we are going for
we are norming this thing
like if if you
oh man if you
um
i'm trying to
you wouldn't read a children's book on
much anything else to explain something
to your kid right yeah right you would
explain it now if they showed interest
in it you might then get a children's
book about it so that's that's what i
would say here think think first this is
about relationship building less about
sex how about that yeah that's perfect
think about build you're building a
relationship with your kids
and
is a part of relationship building i'm
letting them know i'm a safe person to
talk about sex in fact i'm the person
i'm your go-to
on this stuff
and it's not weird it's not whatever and
you and mom do that yep
it's private but yep
and i wouldn't bat an eye about it you
don't want them to ever think it's
something to shh doing secret or quiet
right do you hear me on this greg thank
you for being a dad who wants to have
these conversations
oh yeah we got to have more dads and
moms out there
norming sex norming body parts we just
got generations and generations of kids
who
um grew up to be adults and thought
their bodies were something to be
ashamed of and they thought sex was
something to be ashamed of and they
didn't they couldn't say it in public
um
is don't be that dad that berates their
daughter or makes jokes at their
daughter's expense but also don't be the
dad that calls it
the cycle that they may one day be
experiencing either right deal
good deal all right good hey brother i'm
grateful for you um thanks for fighting
the good fight man parents talk to your
kids about sex
god almighty do it
thanks for being good parents greg we'll
be right back on the dr john de luna's
show
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships
i'm talking relationships where you can
be yourself share hard things and know
you'll show up for one another in my new
book own your past change your future
will walk through a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and getting connected
because it's a key part of living a good
life you'll learn why shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous you'll even
learn how to start making real friends
if you pre-order today you'll get over
several hundred dollars of free bonus
items so go to johndaloni.com to take
the next step towards wellness that's
own your past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back and as we wrap up
today's show don't forget go to
johndavolini.com new books out
own your past change your future a not
so complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness
get it get it all right the song lyrics
of the day in honor of our friend greg
salt and peppa let's talk about sex it
goes like this punch it herb yo i don't
think we should talk about this come on
why not people might misunderstand what
we're trying to say you know but that's
part of life come on let's talk about
sex baby let's talk about you and me
let's talk about all the good things and
the bad things that may be let's talk
about sex
let's talk about sex for now to the
people at home or in the crowd it keeps
coming up anyhow don't decoy avoid or
make void the topic because that ain't
gonna stop it now we talk about sex on
the radio and video shows many will know
anything goes let's tell us how it is
and how it could be
how it is and of course how it should be
let's talk about sex baby right here on
the dr john dolone's show